hello and welcome to
another day of chess on psychology
hope you're having a great middle of
your week
um today is a very special day because
i am trying something new for the
youtube channel
just a little bit i really just kind of
um
want to get your ideas on how this feels
to have like a little
mysterious game so this is a very
cool thumbnail and this was a idea that
i got inspired by to do from
caleb and talia yesterday in our club
meeting
so yeah we're gonna try and guess
this world championship match game
if you're having a hard time guessing it
um
you can only try i mean even if you get
like one of the players it will be great
too if you get
more than that that is perfect and while
we're at it
um i would like to kind of
make sure that my audio video everything
looks good so we have a cat missing up
here
but he's kind of chilling around it's
super windy here in saint louis it's not
cold but
anyways well i see that there's an
increase of followers from our twitch
too lovely
all right i want to go ahead and get
started because
if we end up having more time then i
would like to actually
show you just a little bit more on
the this amazing player but we usually
tend to
be able to analyze deeply in only one
game
uh per hour or so so i'm
uh yeah if we can get through this one
pretty nicely
i will be very happy and this is some of
a
um somewhat of a long game but
definitely not
not the longest but all right so
we're gonna start i'm gonna do my best
not to s not to accidentally tell their
names because i have done that before
all right so we got the roy lopez going
i kind of want to get a little bit in
the chat
on who do who do you guys think it might
be
the opening is a rui lopez um
with knight f6 now
who do you think do you think this might
be a little clue on who is it
okay we got one tall
okay crummy carpool you guys are
thinking um too recent
anyways i'm not gonna go ahead and give
you too many spoilers
but yeah let's just look at this knight
f6
um when we're done with the whole
game i'm going to come back up here and
talk about
how white had encountered different
openings after um in real lopez against
different players around the same time
but i can't exactly do that just yet
because then i would give up
who is this mysterious gm and i don't
want to mess it up i don't want to
give it up just yet all right d3
what do we think about d3 because well
you
the knight have six berlin attacking my
um pawn on e4 so i have to either play
it a little faster or
i kind of have to go for this d3s and
defend it up here however i haven't
really encountered too many d3
ideas oh morphe stated
wow okay all right we are getting some
very very cool ideas
i'm not gonna say it just yet because
well
do you guys have to stay around
for a long time well not that long just
half an hour or so
to get the answer of who is this
mysterious gm
all right i want to continue talking
about this position so
um d6 is what black played
but in um if bishop c5 was played
this is something that's more more
desired more recently compared to when
this game was played
and white can easily try and respond to
with either
c3 and then castle early d4
or white could try to oops just castle
and that's another good way but as a as
with
pretty much any roy lopez white's
eventually going to want to do this d4
so it's just a matter of
trying to get prepared for it
there are some interesting inputs
on still who this champion is
i'll tell you what i have seen the
answer in the
the chat from one or two people
but um let's keep the mystery
let's keep it more chest-related so i
wanna
i wanna come back circle back to the
chest part of it and ask you
what do you wanna do as white you know
that black is keeping the bishop back
there
probably gonna fianca do it you know
that you eventually gonna wanna do this
d4 is right
are you gonna do it now are you gonna
start preparing for it are you gonna
cast it what are you gonna do
you have a bunch of cool moves as wise
you have
a big variety but it's really important
to try and um actually
have it set for you being actually able
to decide on where
how to go i'll tell you who is who it's
not it's not
magnus i'll give you that much
maybe every 10 minutes i should give you
a little hint of who it's not
well castle i think castle is a very
cool idea chess bonzo
um castle you don't really have to play
this
castle move you could simply try
and keep it still interesting in the
center
so let's let's just let's still think
about this position
would you want to try c3d4 would you
want to try d4 right away
or are you still gonna go with castle
i am not really a big fan of going
knight to c3 it looks pretty cool
but i don't think it's going to work out
that great
mainly because if you were to do this
knight c3
then you're never going to really do
this c3 d4
let me rephrase it you are it's going to
be harder for you to do the c3d4
and we kind of really do want to do the
c3d4 so it's important for us
to keep that option open
so there's nothing wrong with knight d2
so that's kind of that's not the thing
like you have so many different
moves but you have to try and play it
smart
and um make sure that you're deciding
correctly on which move order to play
because
most of what you are going to be
thinking about right now is the move
order
to be fair the taking on c6 is also
quite interesting because after take oh
we got a cat on the table
pc stop shaking the camera
you're a big boy oh i have a cat
right behind the camera it is so so so
cute all right um
this is also possible now you would have
to be careful with potential bishop g4s
so h3 and then knight c3
and then you would just cast those so
that's something that
actually um white sorry
that's something that black actually had
played
the person who played white this game
had this team played as black in this
position
it's a little confusing um let's call it
mr
w mr w had
played this game uh it was white right
now but in this position
he was black which is which makes it
even more interesting because like you
can see how he would play against this
type of positions
and so our lovely mr w
continued playing
very interestingly trying to form that
kingside attack
and i really actually like this ah kitty
stop shaking the table
and yeah so eventually
in this specific game oh we got a cat
coming by sorry everybody he's a
big mama's boy he needs attention sure
come here let's have some attention so
then
you can go up here tree big boy
i apologize if anybody's ear was
tickled by my cat's tail
fluffy tail but besides that
let's get back to the chest of it master
w
so oh thank you ahmed uh mr
w here played uh
very interestingly and you see it's
ready to just
pounce on this f5 right
so and this is how actually the game
continued and why it is beginning to get
into a funny pickle all i need is like a
cool sacrifice over here maybe a little
bit more pieces over there
but it's just so white is just so so so
helpless
anywho um white ended up losing this
game
and mr w who is playing black in this
specific position
won this game now let's get back to the
um
position we were at now mr w here played
c3 sure you can call it mr white why not
he's playing white in this position
and black simply played g6
so you see i'm a big fan of the fiance
my bishop and roy lopez so to me this is
a this is very
it looks very yummy but you could also
start it with like bishop d7
and then play like this and
this is actually a game that was
in this this position is a game that was
played between stanislaw oscar
in that world championship match which
is not
the same game we're talking about but
it's a little sideline which is kind of
cool to see how different world
championship matches
are like combining together and
colliding
so um
anywho i i do like this g6 idea but
unfortunately for black
g6 was not enough so
um white has a bunch of different
choices now we could start going for
d4 we could start with 92 or we could
castle
who wants what
walter white hello oh my god i've i
i watched breaking bad um for the second
time last
summer actually it's i watched for the
first time in summer
2019 because my coach told me it was a
good show
and then i watched it like re-watched it
last summer just because while i was
bored and i had netflix
maybe i should make it that annual thing
every summer we watched breaking bad
probably a lot of breaking bad
all right so i see that most people are
kind of fond of
um well
if the castle just yet it's a tiny bit
too early nothing really wrong with it
but it feels like it's
just a little too early we could just
prolong it more
which is um
which is kind of the goal if we castle
now bishop g7
is a given ah definitely got some cat
hair in my face
and then we can easily continue with
rookie one
and this was again another
world championship sorry another world
championship match this was another game
by another world champion
smithslope actually played this um as
white about maybe i want to say
50 years ago no if my math is right more
like
70 years ago yeah yep
geez so yeah this was another game that
another world champion played when
the game actually went pretty swiftly
and as you can see white is actually
having a lot of fun in this game a lot
of coupons to poke
a lot of lonely haunts to eat a lot of
center things to do oh that just looks
amazing so yeah we have this cool stuff
going
but um
let's go back to our
question of should we cast or not well
castling is definitely a possibility
but um what if you think what do you
think about
[Music]
d4
[Music]
heisenberger recipe whoa what is
that
are we still talking about breaking bad
because you guys are going to make me go
watch that again aren't you
you see i love my cats but sometimes i
just
react to it for no reason like
most of the time i'm fine but at the
same time
like right now i should probably i
should have probably had an allergy pill
handy
but yeah you're gonna hear me sound
very interesting all right let's keep
this
go rolling as long as we can
all right um the pro well exactly when
you play d4 you want to do d5 don't you
so um black's best choice is to do this
bishop d7
and kind of hold on to this
pin well i mean i guess block your spin
take care of this pen take this pin away
maybe that's the best way to see
yeah and then after
if there is a take take take take now
white still has a tiny bit of advantage
because of space because this bishop is
kind of blocked
this bishop is not but it's still very
very playable
so um this was also very interestingly
this d4
was actually played in another world
championship match
um maybe not world championship but a
match between steinitz and zuckertort
so it's very interesting on how we all
these world champions
play all these different moves and it
all comes together
so in the game white played
knight to d2 now the idea is
i want to try and get my knight closer
to this side
first and then decide on my castle
situation
however one thing that i don't think
um is it something that you should keep
in mind
is like even if you get to go this nice
g3
your knight is a little bit you know uh
in a pickle
so that's one of the things that you
should definitely keep in mind
when you start with your plan of getting
the knight to the other side
especially when there is kana and g6
anywho um white
what do you think white should do your
knight is all the way here so you might
as well think about getting it more
activated
or you could try to get this bishop out
or you could try to
activate this bishop so you have a bunch
of options
one of our chat is saying
that he's not a cat well i wish i was a
cat but
he's the only cat
being all cute
all right thinking about spirit bringing
the knight out
good choice because well you gotta start
castling soon
bishop g5 definitely another idea yeah
i like knight e3 um
however this move of knight e3
was actually played in um
so this is a world championship match
and this is
actually game four of that match but
in like game two of the match so
two rounds before white had already
played this knight e3 and um
the game ended in a draw so white wanted
to
try something a little different so yeah
that's kind of why white didn't really
go for this knight e3 line
in this game because he had already
played it literally the last last two
rounds
uh well two rounds ago so why didn't
really want to try an id3 anymore
knight e3 if one knight e3 was played
then it could be responded
by d5 and then just trying
to get to this d file
and this is a very interesting and white
does look like it's doing
pretty well however it's important to
keep in mind that
well because this game entered a draw
white did not play the move knight e3
anymore so white made a tiny bit of
change and started with bishop a4
honestly again i think i do i do
sincerely think that 93 is a pretty cool
idea that g3 is a pretty doable idea
however white just wanted to do a little
bit of um
change change is good right so he played
bishop a4
now after bishop a4 black played knight
d7
there are other options such as bishop
d7
d5 what do you think do we like any of
those ideas
trying i'm gonna highlight it for you
while we try to
get a little deeper on them does anybody
like any of these
lines starting with knight d7 or bishop
d7
or d5 what do you guys think
d5 i think d5 is definitely interesting
surprising well maybe not surprisingly
but kind of ironically
so as i said this game that we're
looking at is game
four of the match between these two
players and uh in game 14
so 10 games after this but in the same
match
black actually did try d5
and it was pretty sharp and it had a
very it uh we're gonna
give it a quick look on how that game
wins but we're not gonna go
too deep into that game because we are
still focusing on our line of
not d5 but uh in game 14
of these two amazing players
that's how it started to go you know
it's kind of interesting because this
in roy lopez specifically we don't
really see this bishop being
this involved in this diagonal because
there's usually these a6b5 ideas
but in this game that's not the case and
i think it's pretty cool
so right now we are not looking
at the game that's well
this is the question against the world
championship game however
we are looking at the same match just
game
14 of it so which is
quite interesting because that's
something that i also talked about
last week how you um you had to kind of
repeat
the same openings over and over again
because there were so few known openings
um before computer age
and it was so hard to actually trust
someone to
be able to collaborate with them and to
actually
get these um get these
um lines and preparations whereas today
you can wake up and be like all right
today i'm gonna go play this line
or you can work on an opening for a few
months and like
instead of playing uh e4 you can start
playing d4 or you can start playing
french or caracan or there's so
so many different openings that you're
not bound to just play
e4 e5s and it's kind of funny because
i've heard
so many stories of super gms
when they've like prepared a specific
line that they don't really play
often um and they like i think swiddler
whose story i'm thinking about but i
know i didn't just hear it just about
him but
like these grab like super grandmasters
they like stay up all night
prepare this amazing line so they can
against like a specific opponent
imagine if we always play rue lopez and
then we end up wanting to go
play london or whatever and and then you
go to the game
and instead of playing first move d4
they automatically play e4
so it has happened and it's such a shock
but it's interesting because it kind of
shows that
it doesn't really matter how much of a
chess genius you are
you can still make very very
funny and painful mistakes like this you
want to play e4 you play d4 i've had few
feel like that like never
i've really had problem with cast iron
like putting my king in the wrong spot
but i've had problems with like pushing
pawns
like i've been meaning to like push like
pawn to e5 and not
they just stop at e6 and i'm like why
did i just do that
so brain freeze is a very common thing
anyways i'm not saying uh
i i highly doubt that this was a brain
freeze in this game but my point being
that
it's so interesting that the same
opening
kept happening over and over and over
again
anyways uh this game continued uh
like this and as you can see it's a
pretty cool game
because this actually this is my
favorite position because you can't
really take over here
kaboom you can't really take that kaboom
and anyways uh my point mean that white
ended up winning this game
this was game 14 of the match
oh my god look at this crazy piece
activity
maybe bishop c6 at some point
oh boy that's even way better than what
i had in mind
yeah so as you could see
this um i really have to be careful not
to say the name
and this game 14 of this mysterious
match ended up with white winning two
so let's go back back back this was more
like a sideline for us to enjoy
some crazy tactics but in the real match
and well this is a real match in the
game at hand which is game four of this
match it's getting a little complicated
for me to keep track
uh black played knight d7 bishop d7 is
also
possible but it's not that necessary
i mean um bishop d
through bishop d7 was actually
a played in another world championship
match between schneiders and lasker
but uh white ended up winning and i
don't really want to get
too deep into that just to mention like
you can
still do knight e3 and you should still
save your bishop
and you get to actually form a king side
attack that's how
that's as deep as i want to go for that
line but what about
knight d7 knight d7 now
what should i do with my king do i still
want a shortcaster
or are we somewhat thinking about long
castle
is there anybody thinking about lawn
castle
also a little mini announcement for
those of you who are here
please stick around because we
want to um when we're done with
this segment so in about half an hour so
we are gonna switch to twitch that's my
favorite line switch to twitch
and analyze your games so please stay
around
and have a game or two ready to send for
our twitch channel
so we have specifically increased
the game analysis from one hour to
two hours so we are we will have enough
time
to enjoy and so yeah
please make sure to stay around
and do that
anywho um we should definitely get this
knight out that's
the priority because we spent so much
time bringing it from b1 to d2 to f1 we
got to put it somewhere we can't just
keep it here
so let's go knight to e3 um i'm not the
biggest fan of knight
g3 just because even if you start
pushing this pawn
your knight here is still a little
misplaced we could be under direct line
of fire
it could be smacked by like h pawn and
you're kind of blocking g pawn too if
you
magically want to start pushing it you
can't so
we have to be quite careful on that
so knight e3 let's say poke my the
knight comes poke my bishop i save the
bishop
and black also does this cool thing
now quick question
anybody here want to play h4 if you
don't want to play h4 you don't have to
you can easily castle
but which one do you think we should go
for
unfortunately or fortunately this is
not a nimzowitz game
all right so i see that you are
considering
h4 more seriously
all right so i see i don't really see
any votes for castle so
i'm assuming that most of you want to
continue with h4
yeah i like that h4 seems to be a lovely
choice
let's continue with h4 um
after h4 black has to be very careful
because well first of all what
if after h4 black
does this weird thing of
h5 what would you do was white
any suggestions
where is caleb i believe caleb
is busy
managing
i'm your new caleb he still teaches uh
two of his classes i believe just on
different times
yeah i became caleb about few weeks ago
actually maybe a month wow it's all
almost has it has already been almost a
month there we go
yeah all right so this idea with h5 if
h5 happens
the fun part is we can't do this weird
g3 because after
g3 f97 boom d4
if f5 boom i'll take it and
then i will simply start to poke around
here and now queen is 5 also coming up
so black has to be very careful he can't
just play whatever if h6
boom h5 boom knight f5 a lot of boom
booms
if black tries to be funny and plays f5
what do you think we're gonna do shall
we take that f5
i see some g-pawns oh it is 6 a.m in
india
wow well thank you for being awake and
watching well we can easily take it
after take then we have boom d4 opening
of this
lovely bishop if e4 boom knight g5
take take take check king got a move
you bring this knight now you're
attacking the queen the queen ah
no well if queen takes thank you but if
the queen moves
then boom knight f4 so
many cool ideas so yeah
there's like it's just really cool your
king is still in the center
but it is not really going anywhere so
that's the beauty of it
now let me go back back back back
now we played h4 let's say black
is uh still very awake and alert and
plays knight e7
now what do you think we should do as
white uh also
i wanna um i wish i could say boom
during my games i don't think that's
illegal
uh i'm gonna ask you for
another question well i mean i'm gonna
ask you that question
but so if
you were um let me actually hold on let
me rephrase i'm gonna give you a little
motivation
as soon as
well i was gonna say as soon as we cast
yeah as soon as we cast though i'll give
you a very big hint
on whose game is this
so make sure to find the right
way right moves because we're not just
gonna castle just yet
so what do you think
g4 looks interesting but our last one
was h4
so why not to just push this why not
just continue with the same idea
now after h5 you're not really going to
take that you're not really going to
push
so the tension will stay and black is a
smart
black is just gonna play d5 now
we take this bad boy question
what should this be taken back with
which one do you think is better
see that things for 30 minutes and boom
you see that's kind of why i've grown
used to playing online chess because i
can't say boom
when i'm playing um when i'm playing in
real life i can't really speak boom
so that's a slight issue
believe me i want to but i just don't
think my opponents would be as
excited about my saying boom
that's the thing which one should you
take it back with
all right sparky you are correct you
should take it with the h pawn
because after h takes g6 now we have
queen e2
next we're going to do long castle
however
each taking is the best one because when
you take with f
even though it looks pretty cool um
if there's going to be long term attack
with the bishop over here long-term
attack over here
it's just not really um that's pleasant
so that's kind of why it should be you
shouldn't
in this specific game take it with the f
pawn
so now take take
now how are we going to continue
it's this king and queen in this line
giving you some chills it's kind of
giving me little chills
little chills
nasty form it's unnecessary
um i'm trying to
exchange bishops i also think that's
just a little bit
too too passive
yeah exactly sebastian let's get the
bishop out let's poke the queen you
gotta move the queen
and keep in mind you can't really be too
adventurous you can't really get too
close to my king you can't really go
i mean you could but it's still uh going
to be under attack and queen c6 is your
literally
best move you still keep some pressure
queen e2 thank you i manny
let's say black is uh black
black in this game played bishop d7 what
do you think about a5
because white's probably gonna do
lancaster right so a5 might want it to
start some pokey ideas do you think that
gets interesting
queen trying no i don't want to do rick
s4
just yet we could just play a4 and block
it
yeah exactly block it with a4 thank you
good job roberts yes and if you try to
poke me
i'll just stay around
all right so after queen e2
the black played bishop d7 we're getting
this bishop
out so now is it time to
finally castle on
move almost 20 move 19 is it's finally
time to freaking castle it's been so
long
is it time to castle now i'm annie i've
been
um i got a suggestion to try to be more
mysterious with my games
so i'm trying this new thing to see if
people
like it to know who is this mysterious
gm
yes it's time to cast off for the love
of god let's castle
so now i'm gonna do a little
um let's do a reevaluation
re-vote or whatever what do you think
who is this game between even if you get
one of the players right
i will say that you are right about one
of them
or if you you can give me a year too
this is definitely a world championship
match just game four of that world
championship match
white ended up winning this world
championship match
as a whole and white also did win this
game did win this game
so any any votes
on who is this mysterious dude
or dudes
also while you guys are thinking i'm
gonna praise my bishops a little bit so
they said this bishop is very very
nicely placed over here
and it's kind of just put bringing
pressure
um at the same time my other bishop
on e3 or white's other bishop on e3
is kind of um supporting this idea
or for d4 square you might want to play
d4 someday
you are stopping all the four things
that could happen
unfortunately it is not a well evan
track even though he's an amazing player
this is way before the age of computers
i saw yep ah meda i mean
you got it you're actually correct good
good good
good guess or good educated guess
anyways good job yeah i have a feeling a
lot of you knew this was
staying it's first of all because i am
such a huge
fan so yeah
so what do we think
it is actually um medellin got it right
this
is it's versus uh
trigorin yeah it's almost 1900 it's
actually 1892.
it's all type of game all right let's
keep going with this
black played rookie 8 and this is a
this is an amazing move we have
like seven more moves left on this
position so
i'm gonna i'm gonna ask you to try your
best to figure out
this move i'll give you some hints
well it's obvious that the game is going
on in the king's side
it's also obvious that needs white needs
more pieces on the king's side
so those are some of the things that
definitely needs to be addressed
how can we bring more pieces basically
how can whites bring in more pieces
knight g5 interesting but the problem is
knight g5 you also provide
too much access to your king side to
your king side and to your
um eventual road
rash to king let's say if you play
knight g5 if take
take could take over here is attacking
this bishop i was attacking this pawn
it's um not exactly what you would
hope for bishop g4 coming up we don't
want to exactly give
black all these chances
[Music]
rookish for interesting but we need to
bring in the queen and that's i believe
why the movement knight was suggested
however right now your knights kind of
are right over here we don't really need
to touch that
how about just queen f1
it's it's kind of weird move i agree
but you could easily want to commit
bring it up slowly or you could want to
pop it up like that but we have fun
makes perfect sense
you know it's also a reflex you play
rookie eight i'm gonna run with my queen
you come here trying to threaten my
queen i'm gonna say no no
no bye basically yeah
this could have fun i really do like
this one with coin f1
let's say if knight goes to f4 then
simply we have d4
that's that's one way to have it black
is pretty busted
another way to have it is if you don't
touch your e6 knife and you try to play
that in that side now i get to play d4
remember we said that we like this
bishop to e3 because we wanted to
eventually try to play d4
because if i can get to exchange this
bishop off the table
then i'm gonna have more of
more room to breathe in the king side so
yeah we got that going
so d4 boom boom bam
now let's say black does knight takes d4
do you see any cool tactics because i do
sparky um maybe but
your queen really needs to be in the
king side so coin going to d2 doesn't
exactly serve that purpose
we want to try to be as close as humanly
possible
cake with bishop no always think of a
checks first good job you guys
check check boom and
if not that if something like queenie
for
queenie 4 seems to be the most
interesting and it was much later
suggested
by um kasparov
and kasparov after this queen e4
well what about knight f3 you wanna you
know
still open it up you wanna eat over here
for free you might wanna do a knight g5
cool thing
you might do bishop d4 cool stuff so you
got a lot of things going
knight f3 queen away boom queen d3
and attack on d7 and g6 it's
very very cool position basically it's a
bunch of boom boom boom booms
so what if bishop d4 as happened in the
game we're almost done with this game
let's push a little bit more
any suggestions we should definitely
take it back but with what
exactly tweak it with drop thank you no
glitching
if if night takes then we have a very
very cool tactic
right here where is my tactic
if you want i can say it in the mother
of dragon voice of where are
my tactics or
where are my checks
i should be in the mood for that she had
a very interesting
wear on my dragons quote
i need music background for that but
where
are my where are my tactics seriously we
just gave up a rook so where's my tactic
uh uh if you take this too fast it's not
going to work because rook f6
will block it careful we want it we want
to do it the right way
we need this bishop exactly rook h7
thank you john doe
take boom you gotta move this king
boom you needed this bishop to stay here
to go to h6
you get the king up another boom
king e5 and queen takes d4
it's almost checkmate if you play king
f5 just
one way to checkmate two way to
checkmate i kinda like g4 more
it's more powerful so yeah
a lot a lot of fun stuff this game
was a game between stanis and chigorin
in world championship game four
hawa hawana i cannot say it correctly
hawana 1892
and this is another game i'm a very big
fan
of the giant like the secret chase
the giants of strategy giants of
innovation
they have a bunch of really awesome
books i strongly recommend them
this is something that i found from that
book and it's extremely cool
so i strongly suggest that
if you're looking for some cool books to
read definitely status yes
um all right so with that in mind i am
going to
tell a momentary goodbye to you however
don't go anywhere make sure to pick a
game
and meet me in twitch in about 10
minutes
because we are going to be analyzing
your game
through leeches so please feel free to
join us for that um be sure to send your
game
we're gonna be there for two hours so if
you come here and if you see this video
in an hour or so you still have a lot of
time so make sure to join us on twitch
and send me your game so i can
analyze it for two hours alrighty
perfect i will see you in about 10
minutes